do you ever have any regret  about how things played out you know the  the  the main thing for me i think reason i  don't have any regrets is because  i got over the 10 000 yard mark that was  something that was important for me  to to say okay that my time playing  football on the field in the nfl wasn't  wasted because i accomplished something  it was productive and yeah and and i did  it in 11 seasons and one of those  seasons only lasted a quarter because i  tore my pec  so essentially i almost averaged a  thousand yards a season  and considering i didn't start for half  my career and considering i was out for  a year then back in  and out for a year then back in then out  for a year and back in  that i feel like i did it and i did it  my way and so i  i don't have any regrets